alors dans le film je crois Godefroy de
Montmirail vous appelle l'essuiku voilà
oui Thierry m'a donné le même surnom
mais pas pour les mêmes raisons en tout
cas
et maintenant voici mon stagiaire Tom
villa
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui t'a appris de mettre
Nolwenn Leroy mais c'est pas la
chanteuse préférée de Vincent Bolloré
ah non Vincent Bolloré salam Steven pour
moi du moment que c'est pas mano il y a
rien comment ça va Thierry tu vas bien
bonsoir bon on va faire un petit débrief
de l'émission de la semaine dernière
alors sur Twitter les gens trouvent que
vous avez trop forcé avec la promo de
Pattaya le film ah ouais c'est sûr ça
fait trois fois je vous ai prévenu ou
pas Thierry non mais un moment faut
voilà faut y aller mollo il faut que
j'arrête là
elle a pas bougé il y a pas un truc
tu sais que normalement
c'était des cendres de Pascal Sevran bah
là c'est c'est Jean-Pierre Coffe alors
il faut être discret Thierry parce qu'à
un moment je vous jure ça va se ça va se
voir tout simplement voilà donc
qu'est-ce que je vais dire très très
beau plateau ce soir Thierry voilà c'est
c'est un beau coup de diversité il y a
une Québécoise une Espagnole un
pied-noir c'est on est à l'ONU tout
simplement
Victoria Abril bonsoir bonsoir Victoria
c'est la grande star franco-espagnol
avec avec Julio Iglesias et et la crise
financière et non alors c'est vrai que
vous venez pas nous voir souvent
alors là on va tout faire la série Clem
sur TF1 il y a un film en Espagne
nassida paraguer et puis votre prix
victoire qui regroupe toute l'ensemble
de votre carrière donc si vous avez une
bagnole avant c'est maintenant n'hésitez
pas de
en tout cas Victoria vous me cartonnez
sur TF1 que la série Clem et d'ailleurs
j'ai découvert vous mesurez un mètre 57
c'est ça
quoi à 25 cm presque pas la même série
où juillet sur TF1 vous auriez joué un
ange qui claque des doigts
je me méfie avec Victoria parce que je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez il y a
quelques années elle avait elle avait
giflé un journaliste qui avait mal parlé
de l'un de vos films qui n'avait pas vu
Harry habitant bonsoir
Harry je l'aime beaucoup et c'est très
sincère c'est un mec très très marrant
bon ce soir peut-être qu'il serait un
peu moins marrant que d'habitude parce
que le décor est pas penché mais
Ary Abittan les visiteurs 3 ils
s'emmerde plus il fait que des films qui
cartonnent et films à succès c'est Harry
en deux films 20 millions de spectateurs
19 millions 8 et qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
au bon Dieu et 200000 avec Robin des
bois mais c'est là on voit que c'est un
excellent comédien Harry parce que il
joue un marquis et voilà quand même
passé de coco au visiteurs
il aurait pas fait la Vérité si je mens
alors dans le film je crois Godefroy de
Montmirail vous appelle l'essuiku voilà
oui Thierry m'a donné le même surnom et
pas pour les mêmes raisons en tout cas
[Applaudissements]
cœur de pirate bonsoir Béatrice alors
Béatrice Martin vous revenez avec un
nouvel album et ça c'est très bien il y
a un an vous aviez fait partie du projet
la bande à Renaud il y avait toute la
jeune génération qui reprenait les tubes
de Renault en buvant du Rica ça c'était
vraiment bien et puis il y avait votre
prise de mistral gagnant qui m'avait
beaucoup touché mais ma chanson ma
préférée ben c'est votre tube c'est
comme des enfants c'est la chanson
préférée aussi du cardinal Barbarin
s'appelle rose et le single oublie-moi
alors faut faire très attention parce
que Larusso avait chanté tu m'oublieras
et elle avait une nez creux on l'a bien
oublié
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas osé vous poser
Victoria Abril ah Victoria vous passez
votre temps entre la France et l'Espagne
est-ce que vous en profitez pour faire
des des gosses pour pas revenir à vide
c'est un truc au chocolat
est-ce que tu prends une gaufrette au
chocolat pour traverser le c'est un truc
spécial mais si il faut lui dire la
vérité
cœur de pirate pour terminer vous avez
repris Mistral gagnant de Renaud il y en
a nos good Amy Winehouse d'où vient
cette passion pour les chanteurs
alcooliques
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu